>>
All right. I'm here with Cosmo Nadal [ph]
from myERP.com. He made a really great, great
application, very feature rich. So Cosmo [ph],
I want you tell us a bit about what myERP.com
does.
>> NADAL: Okay. So myERP.com is a complete
accounting [INDISTINCT] solution for small
businesses and for the most thing it's free
and online, and of course, it's made with
Google technology and Java. Okay.
>> Perfect. All right. So I see here you have
a demo, so that--could you show us a bit about
how the application works?
>> NADAL: Okay, great. So let's say we have
a customer called AT&T and I want to sell
this kind of personal services. So you can
see here, we have the [INDISTINCT] and we
can have here icons, and go to calls, emails,
meeting, task. Meetings are completely synchronized
with Google agenda so you can have here the
agendas that you have created in myERP.com.
And then you can create here an opportunity
of an account. So let's say that we create
an opportunity of an icons. So, let’s say
that we create an opportunity on AT&T and
we want to sell them, senior [INDISTINCT]
for ten days, that's it. So now, we're going
to convert these opportunities into quotes.
So we just have to put a quote here; we have
here NT&T, customer, and we select here an
opportunity that is previously down. We take
that one for 10 days and for 1,000 letters
per day. So my quote is done. I can print
or send it by email. Then, I go to the sales
process and I would like to convert in one
click my quotes into like a sales order. It'll
go from here to here. Then, I would like to
convert my sale order into invoice. So I just
have to select my sale order and to convert
into invoice, so easy. And at the very end,
I will be able to receive payment from my
customer and say, "All right. I just have
to check that one and to convert this absolute
payment into payments." So, I receive here
$10,000. So then, I just have to go to the
bank and to make my deposits. What is great
is that in the accounting module, everything
is done. I mean that you don't have to make
any entry in your accounting, it's post. So,
if you want to see your accounting collections–so
everything is done here. So you don’t have
to need–use quick books anymore or sales
force, it's a complete web-based solution,
and you can also manage [INDISTINCT] and forecasting.
And we also have a package with manufacturing,logistic,
and special management. So it's free, yes,
it's possible and online.
>> Perfect.
>> NADAL: Thank you.
>> So can you tell us a bit about how great
[INDISTINCT]
>> Do you want to?
>> Okay, go ahead.
>> It was very [INDISTINCT] because we have
no idea how develop a web application using
HTML or JavaScript or CSS, so we are just
a Java developers so it was necessary to be
able to cross with Java. And so it was–if
there was not GWT, there was no myERP on the
web.
>> And also we already had an application–different
publication made in Java, so we didn't want
to move to another technology and so [INDISTINCT]
is a perfect product.
>> Okay. And so you guys are using great on
the front end and that's JavaConnect. How
about the service side, are you guys using
Java on the server side as well?
>> We only use Java on server side as well.
We use Tomcat as the application server and
nothing else supporting these–about to make
migrating of application to App Engine. So,
it probably means that we use MySQL. We are
very close MySQL and we use ActiveMQ messaging
system. And App Engine doesn't offer us to
use this technology in App Engines. So, we
have to stick with our hosting–hosting choice
that is Amazon EC2.
>> MALE: So you guys haven't considered--haven't
[INDISTINCT] that has been a limiting factor?
[INDISTINCT]
>> Yeah, the database and messaging system
of course we are using GMS with ITMQ, so App
Engine cannot–doesn’t offer us to use
this kind of technology. We have to use big
table as a store engine,
so we cannot.
>> All right. So, one of the biggest–one
of the best features about the web toolkit
and what's the reason why we have been using
[INDISTINCT] in first place is because of
the customer browser. it let's you default
Java code while you’re running the browser
[INDISTINCT] It looks like doing a step-by-step
plugging your Java decoder tools. So, have
you guys used that [INDISTINCT]? How essential
was it to your development?
>> Yeah, we are using the [INDISTINCT] because
we can run that application really fast and
we don't have to compress so it doesn't take
time. And when we make some updating for Java
code, we just have to refresh the [INDISTINCT]
to see updates and that's so we can debug
like Java application, standard Java application.
So, it's really interesting for us and it
was life.
>> You can't be very productive using the
[INDISTINCT] mode.
>> Yeah, because compiling take longer. Compiling
take a lot of time, so we are saving time
by compiling epecially when you are on the
verge, you don't have to compile everything,
you just have to refresh and to see [INDISTINCT]
directly.
>> Right, right. Finally, whatever you did
get stuck, the quick online community has
been pretty helpful and pretty active. You
guys want to see me there when [INDISTINCT].
So, how fast can you even view...
>> Coming here is great. It’s getting bigger
and bigger.
>> And believe me I can [INDISTINCT]
>> Guys from Google on the forum on the Google
group so we can get directly from the guy
that develop Google web toolkits, so it's
great. Also, we can contribute to the community
by helping each other, so it's very interesting.
>> Oh, we both do some blog on things like
that, so we all have to improve our [INDISTINCT].
It’s really...
>> It's very much appreciated. It's very much
appreciated.
>> Yeah.
>> Especially for new technology.